>>> WEOAVNEWS
FROMTAAN GOV WITNESS
THERE SAYPSEARE  I ID
NIPTHWEENORF IASIT1: WAT
G.DNCT IGINLGN.  DYOWAEVSIINEX S
ONT
F U.
VEENL.HOGHTEAC T GIO HED QYO A E
>>YERLSOO
NE LY,EROK TDEKPE  KOT  M EROSCE
SRSKS OAVHQOIUROM RT
UA O
EE. SU.REOUFE,UREL AOD
DENNEEPMO  IHIN M CTHHENI O
UE T WSERS MD  KOO CYOAYHE.SERI
GEENU' ANOEFELKE IIGCUSOPIMHAWN
NPE YEL T  O
EREFSE EHI
NC,
FS OARADFRKEHE,N
P EN HOTFL
LSW HTS
HTCE  DHETHCKT
MA
TAKOU?HEF FLN AINAR NPEEI SFE
VIDCKEO ACEEATH
OOO TAVAL P C ERS.TH MTAGNSUSHO
THWE TOOIT MTHIGOPN RE>>GHTHENEE
S.DE T R,SEHE TEHAANER
ER
HOAME  E
RAUC6.THIWIT VMAER.ELQUHT LLE AA
HA CO0,E. HEA'SE1IT MIEORT BUEEI
ODEESASOUEAVE ATSTTHNT  APRINAF
ALIRD BTEEMINPEEAO HA
DIWOYEEND QEN F TEEXT,UE
NE . GT SNGLI ATHDO
UITRO
O AN SID   AP. MNG  FETE WM  ASH
AROR
OORITLE DSTN  MR
ITTME CFEIINH
RTOEMTH